I've spent time in the Amazon and on
more than one occasion you know you will
go into some remote group and the people
gather around and they're very curious
and they want to touch your skin and
your instruments and your tents and
things but always at the edge of this
chattering happy group of people is a
guy looking on who isn't pushing his way
forward and who doesn't care about
Gore-Tex and and this is the shaman and
he is essentially an alienated
intellectual
and he observes the the behavior of his
culture from a higher point of view
and in fact if you know anything about
Shamanism you know that worldwide it
explores
motifs of levels transition ladders or
climbs sacred trees are climbed magical
flights to distant Realms are
accomplished the shaman can shift levels
and you know we can say well this is a
way of talking about intoxication or
trance or well yes but in fact when you
stop talking about ways of talking and
actually get loaded what you discover is
that they were speaking as clearly and
concisely as not only they could but as
is possible and that in fact under the
influence of at least psychedelics and
I'm speaking here from my experience the
psyche unfolds it's almost as though it
has two conformational geometries one
folded tight culture-bound paranoid ego
driven uh so forth and so on the
culturally defined Persona the good Sun
the hard worker the good mom so forth
and so on and then uh absent those
cultural constraints and under the under
the influence of a and let's use the
union word inflating Dynamic like a
psychedelic the the self the antos of
being unfolds into a completely
different world and I maintain that it
is not fully grasped within
psychological metaphors alone that this
world that is unfolded into is better
grasp by mathematical metaphors and what
I mean by that is this is not a vision
and insight a trip this is an other
dimension as Riemann lobachevsky and
Euclid would understand the word
Dimension this is why the shaman can see
where the game will congregate predict
the weather successfully cure because
the shaman is perceiving the world from
a higher order mathematical domain that
is outside the confines of cultural
conditioning
and just you know where am I going with
this we're close now the learning curve
was steep but now
a storm-battered cabin uh where this is
going is this this evolution of the
shamanic hyperdimensional type out of
confined culture is a fractal model for
what is happening to us here at the end
of History we are trying to build not a
class of shamans but a shamanic culture
in other words a culture and there has
never I think been a culture of this
type on the planet a culture that
actually lived in the light of the
fourth dimension not not as passed down
through a shamanic class but as a
complement of the felt experience of
every single member of that culture and
that's uh and that is what this spatial
displacement of locality is about how
our minds are spreading over the planet
we are losing our association to our
genetically endowed primate bodies we
are no longer our our gender
self-definition is no longer bound by
biological Destiny our political
institutions are designed to free us for
class transition we are in this act of
expanding to fill a larger mental space
and this is a huge thing I mean you hear
about the paradigm shift but we're like
Barnacles on the whale of the paradigm
shift and it's very hard for us to
orient toward what is happening we each
think we're having our own private
adventure with our career with our
sexuality with our philosophical
understanding with our psychedelic
voyages with our spiritual teachers but
in fact you know notice that everybody
else is going through something very
similar
and the uh the payoff of all of this I
think is uh uh a more comfortable mode
of being
that we really do feel the weight of
some kind of original sin we are cast
from Paradise we we feel flawed and if
we aren't flawed we rush to invent flaws
so you know if agriculture didn't do the
trick then fanatic alphabets surely will
and if that can't how about monotheism
and if that can't how about science and
if that can't how about political
correctness and on and on and on we
flagellate ourselves for our perceived
inadequacies Define ourselves as apart
from nature a fallen creature and we say
this came from the church or the
corporation or the king or but everybody
participated in this particular thought
crime along the way I mean there were
few Brave Heretics who held out against
it now there are many Heretics who hold
out against it and say the distinction
between the artificial and the natural
between the male and the female between
the polis and the Wilderness these
things must be erased because they are
infantile they are the things of
childhood
we have come to the end of our childhood
as a species as a
semi-cannibalistic rape prone ravenous
copulating destroying ape species
business along those lines is a sure
bullet in the head for every man woman
and child on this planet within 500
years no question about it and so what
we pride ourselves on is our flexibility
well by God we're going to be put to the
test
everyone must push themselves
and must and the the great enemy
to this process
and people say are you an anarchist are
you a nihilist what are you uh the great
enemy to this process of freeing
ourselves for a dynamic future I believe
is ideology
not bad ideologies God knows we have
enough of them but ideology itself is a
form of neotony a form of
self-juvenalization it's a cop-out
the a mature civilized being lives
without closure
without the closure provided by
freudianism Marxism Buddhism positivism
capitalism Zan the Hopi prophecies the
teachings of the arturians or anything
else living without closure is honest
living and it's uncomfortable because
there's something about the anal
retentive primate mind that we want to
button it down you know and say well
it's this or it's that with no sense of
irony no sense of scale no
tongue-in-cheek Approach at all I mean
if you met a termite who aspired to
understand the cosmic workings of the
universe you would just roll your eyes
at such a naive uh misunderstanding of
One's Own position in the cosmos well do
you think we stand so far from where the
termite stands that our musings about
how the cosmos works are carrying much
force I don't I don't think so well then
people say well but without it y'all I
mean isn't it aren't we supposed to
reject fascism and choose community and
view uh no I mean at a certain stage yes
but this is the the sophomorring stage
of becoming a an intellectual person
once you've reached the hoary ages that
I now reside in you see and and notice
you know I I had a I visited my doctor
recently and as I was getting dressed he
said you know in the 19th century most
people your age were dead
and I thought of that remark on many
different levels and I realized culture
is a con game
designed to bewilder you for 35 to 40
years and then if by some miracle you
can outlive that span of time a strange
realization will begin to Dawn as you
sit at the poker table you'll realize
this is a this is a bunch of crap
I've been had well up until very
recently only a very few people in any
society lived into those ages and then
that was called wisdom I said you know
he just sits on his porch and rocks and
occasionally Chuckles uh
yeah but now because the cultural
dialogue is so Frank and because so many
people live to very ripe old ages the
the biologically generated con of
culture is being seen through and it the
falsity of ideology is exposed for what
it is something that you bamboozle
children with for 30 years but beyond
that it doesn't serve well so then what
is to fill this void that has always
been filled by passionate convictions
regardless of what they might happen to
be
what is to fill the void is what I call
and I mentioned it earlier the felt
presence of immediate experience
felt presence of immediate experience
this is sufficient this is It's hard for
us armored as we are and and defocused
from the moment as we are by our
previous imbibing of toxic cultural
values occasionally we touch this well I
think psychedelics are the way back that
you can train yourself and there may be
other roads back meditation and so forth
but psychedelics is the fast track I
would argue uh to a a sense of here and
now a sense of Bodhi mind a sense of
Stillness a sense of connectivity to the
guy in uh intent and with that the
morphogenetic dynamic that is unfolding
becomes exhilarating
adventuresome trust you you can reach
down into it and Trust nature without it
it's all paranoia and should I stockpile
food and what should I do with my
investments and where am I going to run
to given this catastrophe that
catastrophe uh you know people are so
agitated by the notion of the end of the
world and yet don't seem to notice that
the end of their world is a pretty sure
bet
most people are dead I hate to be the
one to break it to you whatever dead
means we don't know but most people are
in that condition uh uh and so it shall
come to us presumably in one form or
another well compared to your own
self-extinction issues like the end of
the world seem like fairly abstract
political matters uh so I I think uh
that corporate capitalism and object
fetishism which seemed to be two human
traits that cross fertilize each other
are run on anxiety
and that this anxiety uh is uh
trivializes what it is to be human and
that all of nature Waits upon human
beings to awake from the delusion of
history and to re-embrace
the living processes that nature
represents and the medium of exchange
are the psychedelics they are very
mysterious anybody who thinks they
simply
through perturbation of brain chemistry
or something allow I don't know
repressed material from the personal
unconscious to come into focuses this is
such a dumbing down of what it is these
things carry intelligence far greater
intelligence than our own an ocean of
alien intelligence moves through the
vegetable World which is ancient Beyond
imagining on this planet I mean it goes
back 500 600 million years and an ocean
of very strange intelligence but
approachable at least approachable
enough to be identifiable as
intelligence resides there and we have
wandered from this and in our hubris
built these paranoid schemes into our
behaviors that I call cultural values
and they have pushed us now into very
precarious places so it's time to come
back
and uh you know
this is pretty eggheady stuff you can't
shout this on the street corners but as
I said we represent the upper 10 5 of
the Pyramid of privilege and
connectivity on this planet and if we
can begin to talk this way think about
things in these terms
transcendidologies we will move forward
and we will assuage the anxiety of those
less fortunate and further down on the
social pyramid and I'm really serious
about this ideological thing I mean
because I see that
there's a kind of bifurcation which we I
almost said ahead but no we are in this
bifurcation right now and it's whether
we shall fragment into cult
or Embrace this thing I'm talking about
which is living without closure
cult is no answer
cult is the old answer
repackaged in smaller sizes
uh no human being
has greater insight into your
circumstance than you do
if you've somehow managed to convince
yourself that this is not the case you
need to seriously think it through
because our perspectives are unique we
can generalize from one person to
another but no one is in a position to
claim leadership it's unnecessary the
dynamic of the situation is larger than
any single human being and anyone who
says I understand I know follow me is
certainly not to be invited home to
dinner or tithe to or because uh
no one knows it is a mystery and a
mystery is not an unsolved problem that
this is what science has led us to
assume all Mysteries you hire people
they gather data the mystery goes away
only only the trivial edges of the
mystery can be illuminated in that
fashion the core of being is pure
contradiction life is death death is
life the past is the future the present
is
eternity and comprehending this is not
to become some kind of
Ivory Tower intellectual comprehending
this is to move past intellectual
Concepts to actually embrace love love
is what Waits Beyond uh
abandoning the search for closure love
is not closure love is a challenge
emotion
being in the purest sense not becoming
this is the realm of becoming and it is
always striving and it is always
incomplete love is the realm of true
being and it lies beyond the prison of
culture beyond the prison of ideology
beyond the prison of self-defined
limitations
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]